do you have any sort of mid-term to
long-term view where we're going or if
you don't that that's fine yeah
well we're we're going in many
directions at once
you know and the question is is is the
fundamental trajectory downhill or
uphill and i would say that depends on
you
western society in particular what's
that western society yes yes no and and
and more globally i mean
i worked on the un secretary general's
report on sustainable development for
about two years and read a very large
number of texts on environmental
problems and opportunities and economic
development and what happened to me was
that i got way more optimistic than i
was before i started reading those books
i mean so many things have happened in
the last
40 years that are so good you just can't
believe it i mean we've lifted more
people out of abject poverty in the last
15 years than in the entire course of
human history in terms of sheer numbers
of people you know when starvation
except for political reasons is now
pretty much absent across the world
there hasn't been any wars in the
western hemisphere for about a decade
that's really something you know and no
major wars plague us at the moment
that's that's quite something given that
there are seven billion of us and
there's only going to be nine billion by
all appearances it's going to peak out
at about 9 billion and my suspicions are
in 100 years one of the biggest problems
we'll face is that there's just not
enough people and you never hear that
but i really do believe it's likely to
be the case
and we can certainly carry 9 billion
people without doing the planet undo
environmental damage and people who
claim otherwise i think
well i think a lot of things about that
but one of the things i don't think is
that that's an accurate viewpoint
i mean we're doing far better than we
were 40 years ago feeding people and we
can certainly
pack in another 2 billion it turns out
that if you want to control population
though i wouldn't really recommend that
as an occupation
um
all you have to do is educate women and
that's the end of that problem then you
also have educated women and we know
that's very annoying but it seems to me
seems to be you know it seems to be
working out it's a great predictor of
general economic development it's
actually i think the best predictor of
the society's future economic
development is the attitude that they
hold towards the education of women and
luckily it's in the positive direction
and so that's very cool and then
it certainly seems to be the case that
the fastest way out of a given
environmental conundrum is to make
absolutely poor people richer as fast as
you possibly can
because then they do things like well
they don't burn wood anymore maybe they
burn coal and i know coal is evil but
it's not as evil as wood
and i don't know if you know this but
1.6 million children die
every year
because of the indoor pollution that
wood burning causes it's like if if the
nuclear industry had a
record like that that would be all over
the newspapers but they're just third
world children after all so
you know the planet has too many people
on it anyways
and so
there's all sorts of things i see that
are so radically positive that it
beggars description i mean india and
china alone have greened an area in
because of agricultural transformation
the size of the amazon and partly has a
consequence of increased carbon dioxide
levels and
semi-arid area
it's either the size of the amazon or
alaska i don't remember which has
greened in the last 15 years
and so these are things you never hear
you have to ferret them out but
as far as i can tell if we got our act
together and actually wanted it instead
of wanting to burn everything to the
ground in an orgy of guilt-ridden
self-destruction we could set up a world
in 15 years where
absolutely everyone had plenty to eat
and where obesity would be the primary
problem it's a good problem actually
it's like oh no you know we have too
much food what are we going to do
that's a good problem and where everyone
was educated because the cost of
education is falling precipitously and
and we could do that in a way that was
actually beneficial to the environment
whatever that is
so
so i would say fundamentally i'm
optimistic but if we want hell we could
certainly have that and you might say
well you don't want hell it's like yeah
really eh
you might want to ask your quest to
yourself that question real seriously
because
there's a party that
would
would wreak vengeance on god for the
catas catastrophic suffering of being
that's for sure
and that's
that's cane
right so no i'm optimistic because i
also don't believe that
our fundamental motivations
are that of a corrupt will
i think that's wrong i think it's wrong
factually
and i think it's
it's an appalling claim philosophically
and it's a
radically destructive claim ethically
demoralizing a terribly demoralizing
claim and demoralizing enough to really
hurt people and i've seen many many
people
maybe thousands of people
maybe tens of thousands of people hurt
by that claim hurt to the
deep recesses of their soul but i would
say like it depends depends on what you
choose to do really depends on what you
choose to do
you know i read once i think this was in
the solzhenitsyn novel although it might
not have been and it's certainly not his
idea it's an idea from one of the church
fathers that god is a circle whose
center is everywhere and whose
circumference is nowhere
nice mathematical model of god i like it
a lot but there's something about it
that's really true you know we we
interact with one another as if there's
a spark of the divine within us and you
say well no we don't it's like well if
you don't then no one likes you so you
know that'll be its own punishment
because we certainly do interact with
the people we value
when we're acting in a manner that we
regard as appropriate as if there is
something about them this of
transcendent and in some sense eternal
value and you might say well you don't
believe that it's like well do you
believe in natural rights
because the notion of natural rights is
predicated on that underlying
presupposition or observation
and you don't believe in natural rights
well
well then again where are you exactly
and who are you exactly
and those are questions very much worth
posing and so
i think that
truth is more powerful than deceit by a
large margin
and i think love is more powerful than
hate by a large margin i don't mean
naive love and i'm not naive about
people i don't mean that at all but i
think it is possible for us to rise
above
the resentment of our suffering and to
wish the best for all things and i think
we can participate in that and you do
that
well by extending your hand to your
enemy to the degree you're capable of
doing that because who needs enemies or
maybe you do but it'd be better not to
have them i think even if they're
convenient targets to defeat
and then truth well that's the
handmaiden of love
and that's something everyone can
practice at every moment if they desire
that
and that's an adventure you know
if you're acting deceitfully you already
specify the outcomes of your actions and
you pursue that but the problem with
that is it's predicated on the
acceptance of your own
authoritarian completeness it's like
what the hell do you know about what you
should have
so what do you do instead you just do
your best to not lie and see what
happens
and what happens
are wonderful things
although perhaps not at the beginning
when there's a lot of mess to claw
through so sorry for the lengthy answer
but it was a complicated question
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you